if your first company didn't work out
don't give up hope you can still make it
you can still have success as an
entrepreneur most successful
entrepreneurs in the world failed in
their early attempts so don't lose hope
I got a question from a reader on
youtube I are born or anger 89 who wrote
in to say I meant to ask you do most
entrepreneurs fail in the first attempt
at trying to be successful there's a lot
of reasons why entrepreneurs will fail
one of the biggest reasons the most
important one is that you're not
following your passion you're starting
the business for the wrong reasons
you're starting the business to try to
make money without having a deep
understanding of what you're trying to
do you have to stand for something
you've got to believe in what you're
doing you've got to feel it and most of
entrepreneurs don't feel it when they're
starting the business they feel exciting
they feel energetic because of starting
a business but not because of what
they're doing you have to believe that
what you're doing is the right thing so
a lot of entrepreneurs will fail and a
lot of the most successful entrepreneurs
in the world didn't have success right
from the start they had to figure
themselves out they had to figure out
what they was stood for they'd to figure
out how to run a business had to figure
out how to get customers they made so
many mistakes along the way and it seems
sometimes funny because you look at
these guys now and you see the huge
successes they've had but if you look at
their stories look at how they got
started a lot of them had no idea what
they were doing Ben & Jerry's ice cream
huge company now highly successful when
they got started they had to close down
their their store and they left the sign
up front saying something like we had to
close down because we don't know what
we're doing a lot of entrepreneurs go
through that progression and a lot of
entrepreneurs had failed businesses at
the start and then started something
else something that was more in line
with what they were doing but they
really wanted to do more in line with
themselves and some entrepreneurs just
kept going they had it right from the
beginning they had the right passion
idea and energy but they made a lot of
business mistakes along the way
she started the Hershey Chocolate
Company he failed in four different
cities over five years went bankrupt got
disowned by his family but he kept going
he kept finding different ways to do it
because he passionate believed in what
he was doing you can shortcut your
success path it doesn't have to take you
five years you don't have to go bankrupt
multiple time you don't have to have
your family disown you if you learn from
the success of other people you model
their success put it to work for you you
can shortcut your path it doesn't
guarantee you're going to make it on
your first try but if you love what
you're doing and you're genuinely
helping people you have to keep trying
you can't get down on yourself to say oh
it didn't work out the first time I'm
going to quit you have to keep going you
owe it to yourself to keep going you or
to your community to yourself to
everybody around you to your customers
the trick is you have to love what
you're doing that's the core of
everything if you passionately believe
in what you're doing it's the right
thing to do you love it it's helping
people you're providing a great product
or service that is badly needed then you
will attain success it may not happen
right away you may have to go through a
huge stretching period for yourself we
are going through uncomfortable phases
because you're learning and you're
growing and you're doing things that are
scaring you if you don't have the
knowledge you don't have the experience
it's going to be harder it's going to
take longer but as long as you stick to
your path and you don't give up and you
don't quit and you believe in what
you're doing and you know what's right
and you continue on then I guarantee you
eventually you'll have success you can't
quit believe if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes you want to do more for you and if
you have a comment about this video or
question for your company please leave
it in the section below I always read
those and I'll do a video reply for you
I always love seeing those comments come
in thank you guys see you soon